on this episode I talk music I talk mum
and I talk about London cuz that's where
I'm at play it up guys
you ask
this is
ask Gary B everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is said 149 of the
askgaryvee show it is a beautiful day
here in London
what square root a park customer a
gossip I don't even know as you can see
we are we are on the other side of the
pond I'm excited I'm clearly here for
the New York Jets game on Sunday which
I'm very excited for you saw my official
prediction yesterday 1914 very excited
so I feel like we're gonna win since I
am 3 for 3 this year predicting jet
games I didn't really want to get too
much of a crowd for this filming but
then got kind of nostalgic rook we can
started putting out some stuff on
Twitter so a couple of our friends have
joined us and so we're scrapping cat I'm
sorry I know you're gonna play the India
role today but we're gonna go in a
different direction and we're gonna
actually just do a series of questions
from you guys like we did in the park in
Madison Square Park in New York so
Stefon we could do a little mash up a
little London New York stuff in the
future as a greatest hits show 149 is
here why don't you tell the vaynernation
a little bit about yourself because
you're living the life of something that
I believe true when I wrote crush it in
2009 so that makes it fun for me hi
everyone well first of all thank you for
having me here hi guys and for I love
you energy I love Gary because you and I
really vibes similarly we had we're all
about hustle and if I have to talk with
myself outside that or the fact that I'm
a hustler I come from was a right Jong
so I was raised in USSR I moved to
Canada
scene now I live in London so my third
poem
you know don't come from a lot of money
basically my parents didn't give me
anything because they didn't have a lot
so I had to hustle myself you know
through school work two jobs you know I
went to school paid my way through
school then decided to drop out and part
of the business with now my husband Alex
icon
Alex get over here not doing a cam I'll
do the camera I'll do you walk this is
not that hard
alright block away man so Alex going you
pick up the story
what so basically we're a dual couple we
have a few businesses one of the main
ones is lots of here it was started the
whole of marketing was just done on
YouTube and it was super organic we
basically just made videos showing how
to use our product which is clipping
Harry something actually Mimi just
learned today I was telling about I'll
say she's like so who's Gary who is this
Gary guy I'm like I mean I've seen some
of you just go you know because I want
to say was that our business that we
built was inspired by crush it and it
was it was a lot I'll be honest because
what Gary did with the wine at that time
we were like you know what this is it
this is the future this is how business
will be done and we truly believe that
going all in providing full value to
people and only thinking about value so
the way we the way we roll is like pure
jabbing we're jamming so much where I'm
in right okay yeah but the hentai on
what right hooks happen by proxy exactly
yeah let me just check on camera make
sure all right so let's get the show
going any any oh actually that kak I'll
do that let you have this part get it
here to have the India part well
actually you know what why don't you
tell the vaynernation about yourself
because you've been sending some videos
to me as well so that's exciting
hi
ah no cat I live in London I'm merging
from Poland and yeah so cat wouldn't do
the India part here yeah let's get get
into this the show
cool alright let's watch you guys say
here one shoe that let's fire can't want
you to ask a question because give you a
second to think of question side
the DNA on
what's the DNA of a good sales pitch um
I think the best DNA trait of a great
sales pitch is predicated on reverse
engineering what that person actually
needs way too many people try to sell
it's really jabbing and right hooking
most people want to sell you what they
want to sell you versus what you're me
so one of the reasons I think I've been
successful is whether I'm selling a
bottle of wine or I'm selling bread
myself or I'm selling vaynermedia I have
a thing
but I'm reverse engineering you meaning
people used to come into the store and
one of things I was proud of is people
say you have a good red wine I could
have and I would always say well what
are you gonna do with it and I was
stunning to me how many people were
taken aback by that because every other
like their store wine shop would just
give them something they wanted to sell
oh I'm giving it to a boss well then I
would go with something that had name
brand equity that made them look good
who I'm trying to impress wine friends I
give him something nerdy so their DNA
the core DNA is uh is reverse
engineering and I think the other part
that really matters that is is I do
think passionate energy cells like
monotone not pairing like not believing
so I think fundamental 100% all in
belief and then reverse engineering what
they need that makes them
alright okay I got two what else ever
the main one yes why do you why do you
do what you do what gets you out of bed
in the morning like what's the main
purpose of what you do for me it's
pulling at two opposite directions one
is very noble and one is very selfish
one I'm aware and even before Alex like
I'm aware that my biggest fans are the
ones that have felt the effects of all
of my free information and it has
fundamentally changed their lives yeah
the thought that a human being could
stand right now and say our hat like our
great thing is based on the blueprint
that you put out to the world that is
mind-blowing the selfish part is I want
to win I want to I want to I want to
grow I want to build big businesses I
want to buy the New York Jets uh I want
to accomplish things I want stuff for me
from a legacy standpoint not necessarily
the money but that I'm that guy that I
created the blueprint of future business
and marketing and I want to build an
empire and I'm hired on goodness right
you know when I look at the way Steve
Jobs is positioned he was a genius and
everybody looks up to him but he wasn't
great to people I don't want that I want
to be the version of that where
everybody also comes to my funeral
because I was such a good guy okay
second one can I go further
yeah okay so what's one question that
nobody's ever asked for you ask yourself
over there um you know I always ask the
question that nobody can ask me that I
ask myself what is my own personal
question of am I happy the biggest fear
I have in life is that I don't
accomplish the things that I think I'm
entitled to based on my talent and that
as I get older I become more bitter that
it's easy for me now to give away so
much but if I'm 80 and I didn't get
there am I gonna look back for 60 years
and say ah it's because I didn't throw
enough right hooks it's because I didn't
get my fair share and so I'm always
asking myself are you okay with what
you're doing are you okay with what
you're doing because you're putting
yourself in a position where you might
be
reading what you've decided to do and so
I fear that and so that's the question
thank you yeah I'll sorry girls good
let's go next
get in here tell the Vayner nation who
you are hi I'm Christian Tierney I'm an
18 year old entrepreneur I Ron darling
sponsors groan music genre like big
musicians before their big I've worked a
Macklemore ed Sheeran James Bay and my
question is which musicians are doing
the best in social level
truth is you're so much you're way
better in a position to say answer that
question and I am I'm not paying
attention to what a lot of musicians are
doing but I'll tell you that the
musicians that are doing it best will
understand the framework that created
the greatest bands and artists of all
time which is again it's the theme of
the show in London it is providing value
it is so easy to see what Taylor Swift
is doing it is so easy to understand
what fish and Grateful Dead and dave
matthews van did it is disproportionally
helping an audience and then leveraging
that to get them to buy and so whoever
right now is replying to people on
Twitter and video yeah randomly creating
meetups like you know ant saying happy
birthday to fans randomly not where the
artists that are knocking on fan's doors
and they open it up and ago but
whoever's doing the things that nobody
else is doing that the fans want which
is the touch seriously
Taylor Swift is perfectly executing it
and it matters and it becomes
word-of-mouth and so I don't know
specifically yeah uh but whoever is
bringing disproportionate value to the
people that are potentially interested
in her music and notice I said
potentially interested in her music
that's the key whoever is doing that
that's who's waiting for a minute
thanks so much you gotta be appreciative
Alex do me a favor make sure you round
up everybody's Twitter Instagram
accounts so that we can give a beta plug
so the vaynernation can dig into his
disproportion ability to discover
up-and-coming artists yeah get in here
hey get in here go you go
I'm hi everyone I'm Nancy oh god II at
Nancy Oh judge on Twitter Oh little plug
I'm so as someone who is just starting
out building their personal brand yes
would you say quality of content is more
important or quantity of content oh okay
this is wood should I be putting our
stuff every yes what if I'm not
passionate about it what if I'm just -
no no only suffering passionate about
yes okay cool and now the question
becomes do you have enough right and
that's why I just did that little funny
exercise with you guys we're not all
entitled to have personal brands and
make millions of dollars it's predicated
on if you have the skill like I really
knew a shitload about wine I really know
a shitload about business and marketing
you clearly are doing your thing with it
like you have to decide if you're
actually good at it and you up enough
but you're gonna need both yeah and if
you're great and you've got the content
you can do both but that's where the
rubber hits the road right like you know
building a personal brand is just like
becoming a rock star musician or a
famous athlete or a politician we don't
all get to do it but you know what's
cool unlike the way our parents grew up
in our great grandparents grew up we all
get a chance we all have a camera and a
phone and we all get a chance but the
cream is gonna rise to the top my
friends not everybody's entitled to be a
personal brand making millions of
dollars doing what they want to do at
all times it's just not that easy what's
special is that you get to find out if
you're good enough because there was
millions of people that were good enough
that didn't live in Hollywood that
didn't have parents that could send them
to Hollywood and that's what's special
not if you that we're all gonna be
famous it's that we all have a chance to
create something thank you so much
appreciate thank you get in here
let's go let's go big man all right get
in here Donnie Daniel's Donnie I'm good
dad my mom started a clothing business
for years ago okay but kids clothing
good business okay once help building
our brand then the self taught me is
coasting on like my business building
myself as a yes whatever yes
how do i balance my self desire but my
real desire to help my family out that's
a great goddamn pleasure so a couple
quick questions is your mom since she
just started still small business yes
so I would tell you Danny that you've
got something really going for you
here comes guys get ready how old are
you 21 21 perfect kind of thought that's
where we were go Danny
most people so one thing that's really
pissed me off about London so far is
I've been running around to meetings
starting at 4:00 p.m. there's been
millions of people at pubs and I'm like
are these people working if you follow
me on snapchat you've already seen one
I'm angry
so anyway taking a step back you're 21
you can stay up 18 hours a day I know
that you ran out of your like class
right now to be here so I guess you
gotta bounce some school hours but how
many out I mean you got hours Yeah right
so I work two full-time jobs every day I
work 18 hours a day that's nine hours
every day that's more than a lot of you
work in half a lot of people who are
watching right now don't even work nine
hours I work 18 that's two so I think
you can do both well you just have to go
to less pubs go watch less football as
you call it soccer you just have to do
less [ __ ] like stop chasing the girls
run you just got it you got to work if
you want it and if you don't what you've
got to do is figure out what balance
you've got to do and whether it's 60 40
or 50 50 or 90/10 for your mom for you
whatever you break it down to the way to
really fix it if I have more having more
outfits yeah you know what I mean and so
I've been able to solve a lot of my
concerns my ambition my work-life
balance on just doing more hours to a
net score
just depends on what you want thank you
yeah good all right let's get in here
hey man
once again I'm Phil Phil shake from
Cheney calm and basically I want to ask
you two small questions first one would
be do you believe that unique content is
not the way to go anymore
meaning if everyone is trying to produce
unique content yes it is the way that
it's conservative I believe that the
process of creating unique content is
what we create engagement meaning so
basically instead of you producing a
nice piece of content for me yes that I
go to someone and I created a process
where millions of people create that
unique content and then the glass world
yeah more or less
it's basically instead of engaging with
people just towards the end of the
product that you're producing you engage
with them throughout the process of
making this product with you are you
looking ording the yes you're all it's
all part of them yeah I mean I think
that's engagement and interaction with
other people I think there's potential
in something like that okay for sure all
right and one more question what do you
think of Casey les that's B have you
tried a I'm an investor okay so my my my
thought of it is disproportionately
jaded not to mention I love Casey's been
on the show as you know uh I think it's
absolutely going to happen of course I
desperately want Casey to do it because
I love him and I've invested in the
company but right now the amount of
people that would be interested in
seeing what I'm seeing is high meaning I
really would actually I don't so I don't
love music concerts so much but I would
absolutely right now if you worked at
scale the right way the way I see it in
the future through glasses or contact
lenses if I could watch what Taylor
Swift is seeing when she's performing in
front of a hundred thousand people at
Wembley Stadium that'd be cool I'd watch
that a little bit right I'd love to
watch what an athlete is seeing as
they're going on the field or me in a
business meeting just like as I enter
and how it's how am I you could actually
really figure me out of how I sell just
by how I behave if you actually saw how
I'm seeing it
so I think first person viewing and
disappearing the way life actually works
is going to win and so I hope he wins
but so I believe in the thesis 100%
because look the contact lenses are
coming yeah like they're coming and you
may be able to record and watch your
nothing gonna be knowing if somebody's
recording and watching so that means
we're all going to be living and
believing it's always going on the
world's going in a very interesting
place so I think he's it's very
progressive and I'm excited about it
I think it goes way beyond the phone
yeah and that's why I'm bullish on well
thank you so much thank you guys thanks
for having there one more question yeah
you getting your brother I love it I
love it good hustle hustle
yeah for sure hold on one second oh
alright yeah
so Alex I call you check me out Alex
icon we created Lexi here 500 journal
productivity planner coming out so the
question for you is very viscerally
please uh as you know we built something
similar to you got a sparked off a [ __ ]
yes so did the same thing they did a lot
of jabs didn't put in a lot of work in
years now if you leverage we have built
leverage put the trust your brand you
have a substantial business sound seven
figures yep but now that is been comfy
yours we kind of stagnated yeah because
to sort of my question to my question to
use and I think one of the weaknesses
here is actually scaling yes because we
tried to earning ourselves being a small
team but how do you actually build that
sitting with you most important
questions that how do you build and
maintain
that culture and add that love that the
same love that you have for the business
and other people other people this is a
very is a very Eastern European pleasure
is very common things that so the answer
is you don't
if you expect somebody else to love your
business as much as you you two are out
of your mind and this is something I try
to teach my dad as a young kid oh my dad
you own the business how the hell do you
want them to love this as much as you do
that what you need to do is several
different things the UH first of all
thank you for asking me question I lived
it I did it at Wine Library from people
that are more like you you guys went to
zero to something just like my pops and
how I scaled it was I taught him these
pillars and I taught him these pillars
which is number one get over that it's
over they're never gonna love it as much
as you and if you're lucky enough like I
find like that amazing man behind you if
you can find people that can love it
eight point five as much of a ten nine
point two as much of a ten nine point
seven on a Holy Grail moment out of ten
well then you've won so that's never
gonna happen and it's actually
completely completely disrespectful for
you to even want that from somebody else
cuz you never loved somebody else's
business as much
so why you gonna try to make somebody
else - number one number two the biggest
mistake people make at this point is you
start wanting to cash in on some of the
fruits of this amazing hard work it's a
little bit more exciting to dress a
little bit better to live in a better
place to take a vacation to do all he
said I get it the way to scale and grow
is to have the dollars to continue to
scale and grow if you're doing
everything yourself there's a couple
reasons one your perfectionist and don't
think anybody else can do it - you see
other people do it they do it as an
eight - you're ten and that's not good
enough three you do not want to deploy
the money because you want to use those
monies for other things for yourselves
than other things all three your massive
bowler bilities fix those three and
you'll grow I run my businesses the
first five ten years of their lives at
no profit and I did it and people can
say now easy for you [ __ ] I was 28
years old
I built a humungous business and I was
making $40,000 a year my friends that
were half me and a hundredth of me
making more money have better cars we
can have more fun I was 28 years old
making $40,000 a year and I bailed a 30
million dollar business at that point
that's eating your own dog so get over
yourselves and be thankful that people
want to work for you and get them to an
eight or nine and you get them to an
eight or nine by loving them more but
you did for your audience you need to do
for your employees employees ten times
more biggest mistake entrepreneurs make
they treat their employees worse than
they treat their customers biggest
mistake treat them better than you
treated your audience then they'll get
from a six to an eight and that's
amazing
they'll never get to attack it's not
their business number two decide how
much you want to live great now versus
every dollar every dollar you take that
trip to Spain is three dollars less that
you make three years from now what if
you have still substantial money after
vacations after everything and then I
stick it into people for people but how
do you find these people who are still
eight even there or seven but easy
because you need to treat them better
because you got them you just need to
change the way you're treating and if
they don't get there after you treat
them way better you fire them and you
find people that do react to you giving
them more value than they're providing
well do you understand yeah really not
pulling that one not letting you go oh
here's my thing you can't get how many
employees do you guys have
around the world great
you need to really vet them the number
one thing I would do if I were you is I
would call them right after the show and
say what can I do to make this much
better for you sup we're good good do
you deliver on them yeah great well then
you should be having no problem and then
then I'm a little bit more confused then
either you've not built enough trust
with them for them to tell you the truth
or you're just not hiring fast and I
think we're not hiring good good zone
because we're we're we're trying to have
everybody to be like fully pen so you
know we're doing Eric Eric Eric was what
number play 1717 he watched Boehner go
from 17 to 200 than for personal reasons
he went the boss he's back now and we're
600 what Eric can tell you invent all
the vaynermedia employees from 70 to 200
stick with me year is not an insult
he knows how many four five six seven
and eight
you need four five six seven eights when
you're big everything you can't make
seven 10s that's right you scale and win
that's the secret
it's not about you guys getting seven
people to attend its are you hiring 40
people at 8:00 how about here's a squash
ball so we're at six seven or now it's
for many business retractile you split
them up it's actually a question I
wanted to ask you for a long very long
time if you're starting it's a question
that you wanted asking for very long how
the hell isn't that the question okay do
it now that you needed that preface
Scott okay can squash on okay so the
question is knowing you have a
successful businessman in the bank yeah
everything's great yes it's a
slow-growing everything sausage yeah
yeah but the thing is who you would be
your first five like you have to say
customer service hired yes and one
marketing person but will be your next
five hires
I'd have to look at your business and
understand so first of all Commerce so
first of all I would rock first and
foremost I would reverse engineer you to
whatever you to like doing the most and
are the best at I would surround the
hires around that I'd let you continue
to do that because a lot of people try
to replace the thing they're best at
that's the mistake stay doing what you
do best that and whatever the two of you
collectively do the weakest that's when
you hire in order five next people
whether that's finance HR product EECOM
technology whatever they are but what's
been your most that's higher for you in
that first kind of put in that white
library when you scaled the boys one of
the best hires for you that like the
best hires I've ever made have been the
friends that I've hired that's the big
secret to me but Tom position wise
probably the financial people you know
like the CFO's the the leave financial
person have been the best hires because
they've given me a context to pay cuz
I'm so aggressive I want to spend every
dollar so that gives a vulnerability the
reason I've never gone out of business
is I'm so much better at selling than
everybody else in the world I can always
keep afloat even against my enormous
investment I so I had vaynermedia I
would say mark Yadkin the lawyer
creating legal in house was a huge hire
uh Kelly an early managing director
because she created a lot of context and
then people that look like Eric which
were disproportionally talented and open
for to allow me to mold because we were
all playing a new game people that are
moldable but talented are very
attractive yeah cool thank you
appreciate it
all right guys we're seriously late
right guys thank you so much that was
good that little that that's like that
that himself is a separate video
altogether operations guys thank you so
much watching one forty nine uh that's
about it statement of the day I'd love
to understand what you guys thought
about this and you keep asking questions
I'll keep answering them